have you ever tried to learn a foreign
language in school if so you probably
agreed that learning a language in
school does not actually work out even
if it did work out for you you likely
have some friends family members or
former classmates who took language
classes for several years only to come
out of the process having minimal
ability to speak the language why does
this happen why when knowing another
language is an increasingly important
part of modern life has everyone seemed
to tacitly accept that schools rarely
produce capable foreign language
speakers and better yet how can we make
it better how can we make the process of
learning a language in a classroom
smoother
and more efficient so that every student
has a chance to obtain functional
language skills hi i'm luca from
lucanpedo.com i'm an italian language
coach who currently speaks 14 languages
and i help people learn languages better
faster and in a smart way and in this
video i'd like to discuss the problems
of learning a language in school from
three main angles and propose some ideas
that i believe can help move language
education forward toward a brighter
future specifically we'll take a look at
the student's perspective the teachers
or tutors perspective and the student
teacher dynamic let's start from the
perspective of the student
the traditional model of the classroom
places the student in a passive
subservient role if the teacher is the
sun in this proverbial solar system then
the students are most certainly meant to
be planets stuck in her orbit accepting
the light of her knowledge without
question despite the relatively recent
advent of alternative learner-centered
methods this teacher-centered method is
still the one that predominates around
the globe if you're watching this video
it goes without question that most if
not all language classes you've taken
have been structured this way there's a
problem with teacher-centered language
education though the kind of problem
that galileo galilei saw the answer to
almost 400 years ago when he said you
cannot teach a man anything you can only
help him find it within himself let's
explore this a little bit further
if you're a student then this is what
you must realize and accept that you are
the person who bears sole responsibility
for your language running success yes
you you and no one else
not even your teacher or tutor why do
you bear this responsibility because
language learning is a skill even if you
have outside help it is your job to
absorb the language experiment with a
language make mistakes get feedback and
try it all over again and this is
something that you'll have to do
infinitely many times over the arc of
your language learning journey and
here's the thing about your journey very
few of the thousands of hours you spend
learning and using a language will ever
take place in a classroom or in front of
a friendly tutor instead you'll spend
most of them at home learning on your
own or out in the world with native
speakers practicing using and living the
language let's talk about my experiences
with english and french i remember when
i came to this realization and
discovered i was the one who held the
reins of my language learning success i
had been learning english and french in
school for years and had found little
success with either one i was 12 years
old then and never found anything taught
in my english class to be particularly
enjoyable even when i learned it at home
i found it difficult to make progress
while studying dry textbooks then one
day my parents decided to hire a tutor
to come to my home and work with me
one-on-one the studer did not teach me
english not in the traditional sense
rather she showed me all of the
interesting things i could explore
through the medium of english and
encouraged me to dive into them to my
heart's content with my tutor's guidance
i do into all manner of english language
books movies magazines and so much more
i then became more interested in
language and more confident in my skills
and her feedback helped me get even
better my story with french was a
similar one with a few notable
differences like english french was a
language i had studied for several years
with unremarkable results unlike english
though i had no french tutor to show me
interesting french movies or books one
day however i was channel surfing at
home and happened upon franz do one of
france national tv channels as an
italian living in italy i was a bit
surprised at this but even more shocking
was the fact that this channel
constantly showed french movies and tv
shows all subtitled in french suddenly i
had found the interesting content i had
never had access to in french class it
wasn't long before i spent hours upon
hours every night watching and
dissecting everything i heard and saw in
french and soon after that my skills in
french started to skyrocket just as they
did in english for both of these stories
the common thread is that my language
skills only ever grew when i took
control of the situation when i read
french books practiced quoting american
movies and searched for and learned any
interesting vocabulary and phrases i
found in each in other words i learned
when i was having fun and learning
exactly what i wanted to learn if you're
a student in a language class here's my
recommendation if you really really want
to learn this language then spend 80
percent of your learning time
exploring the language on your own use
your classroom time as a side dish to
your learning rather than the main
course so take initiative and watch
movies read books and binge watch tv
shows and youtube videos all in your
target language if you do that and stay
curious your skills will improve
massively and when the time comes to
have a conversation with your teacher or
tutor take charge there too if you can
this is not always possible with a
classroom teacher but with a tutor you
will usually have the ability to choose
the topic of conversation or even the
types of activities you do together if
you have this flexibility then make sure
you use it to practice your language
skills using the topics and contexts
that most interest you and if you want
to talk about something cool but you do
not know the word for it then ask
collect the vocabulary and phrases that
mean something to you and learning will
come naturally
okay now let's take a look at things
from the point of view of the teacher
remember the teacher-centered approach
from the last section that just won't do
it anymore why because every student is
different what inspires and drives one
student to learn will not be what
inspires and drives another this is what
i found in my 10 years working as a
language coach though each student comes
to me for assistance in learning a
language each one has different goals
different dreams desires and motivations
if i try to teach using a rigid
structure and lead students according to
the way i think they should learn i
would get nowhere maybe a few would
succeed but most would likely give up so
i never tell people how they should
learn or even what they should learn i
use a different strategy instead
what i do and what i recommend you do
too is sit down and listen attentively
as a teacher or tutor it's easy to feel
like you're the expert and that you know
better than your students do but as i
said before language learning is a
journey that students must explore
themselves through their own likes
dislikes and interests though you as a
teacher may be considered an expert on
the language you teach you most
certainly are not an expert on the
internal mind of any particular student
you cannot assume you know what inspires
and motivates them better than they do
so you need to listen and you need to
listen a lot especially after asking
questions ask questions about learning
style hobbies topics of interest family
life work cultural background pretty
much anything goes so long as the
answers you get help you connect the
students more deeply with the language
they are learning ask and listen ask and
listen again
and again the more you listen and learn
about your student the better smoother
and more rewarding your common learning
path will get
the knowledge you gain from listening
will also help you follow the next
recommendation which is to be flexible i
mentioned earlier that being rigid in my
teaching methods would never have gotten
me far in my coaching business sure i
teach students certain learning methods
just like you might teach specific
classes or tutor using specific lessons
but i always make sure that those
methods bend to the needs of the student
and not the other way around this
bending this flexibility is only
possible because i listen to my students
and i learn what they're all about when
i know my students and remain attentive
to their needs i can trim adjust and
tweak my method to them i can add things
that will work for them and subtract
things that will not in the end i'm able
to transform the methods i teach so that
they fit the student like a tailored
suit rather than baggy of the rack
pajamas you can do this too when you
listen to your students use what you
learn to make your classes lessons and
methods more adaptable to their needs
and desires don't be afraid to shake
things up if it means creating a more
engaging more enjoyable learning
experience for the ones you teach
if you've watched up to this point you
might think that since i've criticized
the traditional teacher-based model of
learning that i automatically advocate
for the alternative student-centered
approach this isn't quite true though if
the teacher-centered model suggests that
the teacher is active and the student is
passive then the student-centered
approach suggests the opposite that the
student is active
and the teacher is passive in truth i
don't believe either the student or the
teacher should be passive instead they
should both be active lively
participants in the learning process
back to our solar system metaphor from
earlier it's not necessary for there
only to be one sun which the student
planets all revolve around reality tells
us that there is in fact a better model
to suit our new metaphor a binary star
system wherein two stars orbit a common
center this is how it should be in
language learning in the classroom the
teacher and the student both have light
and warmth to bring in terms of their
knowledge identities and experiences so
students converse with your teachers
teachers
converse with your students each of you
must ask questions of the other listen
and give feedback so that together you
can find ways to make learning more
enjoyable more efficient and more
transformative for you both
for a long time language education has
been largely out of balance teachers
push rigid structure methods onto
students while disinterested students
give up their agency believing they have
no say in what or how they learn ears of
independent language learning and
language coaching have taught me that
for balance to be restored in the
classroom both teacher and student must
take an active role albeit in different
ways students must realize that there
are the ultimate owners of their
language skills whether or not they
succeed has little to do with their
teachers or tutors and more to do with
how often they seek to engage with the
target language and culture on their own
terms when the time comes to use their
target languages actively they must
speak up and direct the conversation
when they can teachers on the other hand
must realize that learning is never one
size fits all each student is different
in different ways and it is through
knowing these differences that the
teacher can design a suitable flexible
learning experience for each individual
learner this requires a deep knowledge
of the student that can only come from
conversing with a student and listening
attentively to what they say if in this
way students and teachers can both
become active engaged participants in
the learning process then we might one
day be able to flip the script and
discuss how rare it is that someone does
not graduate school knowing a foreign
language rather than the opposite
situation we're living through today if
you'd like to read more of my thoughts
on this topic i've left a link to my
blog in the description box where you
can find relevant articles where i
explore this topic further and if you
love this video you're going to love
another one i made about how to work
with your language time called the
perfect language exchange in five steps
and as always thanks for watching and
happy language learning
[Music]
[Music]
you